[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Lewis rck he is uh part
of the uh uh college football and NFL
coverage there uh Espen NFL college
football analyst and uh former
Washington and Eagles director of pro
Personnel Lewis thanks for joining us
explain to me what the chief's defense
did to Lamar
Jackson well I think it's kind of a
two-fold thing uh Dan I think first and
foremost early on you could see that
Steve spagnolo said hey look we're going
to try and make this a one-dimensional
game make this a passing game for you so
when you come out and you try to run the
football early in the game we're going
to play some very very tight up at the
line eight man fronts and our guys our
offens our defensive line is going to
fire off this ball our linebackers are
coming downhill and we're going to try
and discourage you and try and get into
the head of off of offensive coordinator
Todd monin to get you out of that
thinking that you can run against us
because if we can get you into a
one-dimensional game we'll take our
chances you throwing the football and he
played right into that Todd Monk and
offensive game plan played right into
that and that's when spags had him
exactly where he wanted him because from
there he unleashed the five and six man
pressures lots of man coverage in the
back end which they're very very good at
anyway Chris Jones was mean you start
being able to time up the snap count you
start getting a rhythm as a pass rusher
you start getting a rhythm as far as
what routes they're trying to throw and
Lamar never looked comfortable so as
soon as he got them out of thinking that
they could run the football and stay
two-dimensional which was a mistake on
their part then they had them because
that is exactly what they wanted that's
what they wanted to do going in I'm
wondering as we move forward just like
we did with NI yic he won back-to-back
MVPs and I think he lost the third one
because
we thought he's never done anything in
the postseason MH and it did factor in I
think in the voting that he's going to
be a three-time you know back to back to
back and then Joel embiid who had a
wonderful season we saw what Joker did
in the playoffs he won the title I
wonder if we're going to do that with
Lamar Jackson that here he has two MVPs
now but he has very little postseason
success that do voters look at him
differently and I know the postseason
doesn't factor in on the regular season
voting but is he going to be viewed
differently
that he won these MVPs but had nothing
really to show for it in the postseason
I don't think there's any question that
it'll play a part because they're human
beings that are voting people don't
forget and maybe that's part of the
whole MVP voting process that maybe
needs to be re-evaluated as far
as you know look I think some the people
who are voting for MVP obviously
understand that regular season and
postseasons postseason success are
totally different animals and if you're
really going to be considered one of the
greats of all time what do most people
kind of use as the standard for that
it's what you do in the postseason right
and so MBP is supposed to represent you
know in you know as we move on through
history it's supposed to represent a
significant significant achievement
achievement you're the most valuable
player not during a regular season but
overall for your football team you're
supposed to be a guy who impacts winning
at the highest level at the most crucial
crucial times and so people are going to
say well Lamar wasn't able to impact his
football team and help lead them to wins
at the most crucial of times and that
like being the situation yesterday now
there there's a number of different
reasons why things didn't go the way
they went yesterday and some of that has
to do with him there is no doubt about
that a lot of it has to do also
with could they have been more balanced
sure can you should you give a ton of
credit to the Kansas City Chief's
defense there is
absolutely no question but to get back
to your question
question for sure Lamar knows this you
know this I know this we all know this
he will be judged based upon what he
does in the postseason the same way
we're judging dke Prescott the same way
we judge Josh Allen and the same reason
why we love Tom Brady and why right now
well not right now when it's all said
and done we'll love Patrick Mahomes and
put him at the very top explain to me
how Travis Kelce finds these
openings when you know I I was tweeting
about this yesterday so I was kind of
losing my mind about this like okay free
access to guys like Travis Kelce meaning
you let them off the line of scrimmage
and let them kind of work
against it's not really spot Drop Zone
meaning you just kind of run to a spot
and look at the quarterback it's more
man match Zone meaning you match guys
once they come into your Zone but
nevertheless he he's too good to allow
him to play positional basketball
basically against you especially when
you have a quarterback like Patrick
Mahomes who was on the same page as him
where you kind like they they kind of
like to have this unspoken uh
communication to where he knows where to
move slide find Zone voids and Patrick
is just so good at being able to
determine and well first of all move
Defenders where he wants them with his
eyes with pump fakes ball faints
whatever you want to call them and then
they're able to just kind of pick you
apart
now two of Travis's best catches
yesterday were against man coverage
situations where Patrick could only put
it like on the first on the fourth down
conversion where he's rolling right they
have it shut down and he comes back and
he throws that high pass that high deep
Crosser to to Travis Kelce where that's
a Hall of Fame throw a Hall of Fame
catch by a Hall of Fame quarterback and
a Hall of Fame tight end and his first
touchdown against Kyle Hamilton is also
man coverage so you're sitting there
going look we have our best guy Kyle
Hamilton first team All Pro on their
best player and he just one yeah so
sometimes there's nothing you can really
do but when on the during the times when
you can do something like not allowing
him free access not allowing him to pick
you apart against zone defense that
drives me nuts and um look he's made
he's made a living off of that his
entire career and that's why now what
he's the most productive postseason pass
catcher in the history of the NFL not by
accident he's good but a lot of people
have helped him get there in terms of
poor defensive structure and Game Plan
talking to the motherships Lewis rck if
you were in the Lions locker room at
halftime what would you be saying to
your teammates if anything or look you
know if I was if I was on the team I
would I would be saying this hey look
we're dominating the line of scrimmage
we're literally knocking these guys
senseless off the ball let's keep
running it with Jamir and David let's
keep trying to make sure we get it to
Sam and get it to Aman ra Jared just be
smart with the
football and defense hey
look we're going to make sure that Debo
doesn't get loose we're going to make
sure that you know that Brandon doesn't
get behind us and we'll be all right
we're we're we're g to be fine just keep
doing what you're doing but you know
what I mean what happens
is deo came out in that second half and
you could see the urgency he had you can
see how quickly he wanted to get moving
Brock started getting into a rhythm they
kick a field goal on the first drive
they come back you know they stop him on
that fourth down where it's 24 to10
where Bosa gets a nice pass rush jerck
gets a little flustered they throw it to
Josh Reynolds he drops it then they go
down they score then Jamir fumbles then
they score again and see at that point
see San Francisco starts thinking this
is what we were supposed to be doing all
along Detroit starts
thinking okay well you know that
conversation that we just had in the in
the locker room all of a sudden that
doubt starts creeping into your mind as
fans start going you start realizing
this is pretty good football team they
have over there and you know what once
your psyche starts to get fractured like
that it's just human nature man for some
people to get tight it's human nature
for some people to start doing things
that are out of character and once you
feel a certain Rhythm coming for you
where maybe you were doubting yourself
initially and you start making some
plays all of a sudden you start feeling
like okay here I go and we've seen it we
see it in youth sport Sports we see it
in professional sports I watch it with
my 13-year-old son he misses a few shots
in his in the basketball game early his
shoulders are slumped and I'm sitting
there yelling at him from The Stance
pick your head up he hits a
three-pointer next thing you know he's
flying up and down the court and
everything starts to roll and that's how
that game flipped but I'm looking at the
lions in the fourth down decisions I
know we focused on this a lot they
didn't go for it at the end of the first
half they went for it twice in the
second half but if this is week five of
the NFL it's different this is a chance
to go to the Super Bowl I have to factor
that in with the decisions that I make
because there's sort of that pucker
power that you know what these are big
big moments there your thoughts on Dan
Campbell being Dan
Campbell yeah look and I and I've kind
of I've thought about this a lot because
look I I understand that Dan has taken
the
information the win probabilities the
probabilities of success in those
specific situations in terms of being
able to
convert the probabilities in terms of
how you know well how it affects you
know maybe the probability of them
winning the football game if he is the
convert where the chances of convert and
like he's done that all year long and so
he stayed true to who he is and he has
continued to try and be very aggressive
because they've had a a ridiculous
amount of success being successful I get
it um so I get that part of it I think I
think sometimes though when you when you
decide okay so if you're going to in
those
situations like let's just talk about
Josh Reynolds in particular on the first
one all right yes Bosa had a great pass
rush and it affected Jared gof and it
was a little bit of an off Target throw
but you know what if I'm going to go for
it in those
situations one of the things I'm going
to do is I'm going to make sure that the
play that I have dialed up come hell or
high water I'm trying to get it to the
guy who I know is going to be the most
consistent playmaker for me because he
has been in the past too if I'm going to
remain consistent in terms of my
aggression then 14 is getting that ball
somehow some way if I'm throwing it Aman
ra is the guy he's not going to be a
second or third option backside he's the
primary
guy and why wasn't he the guy why wasn't
he the guy in those sit in that
situation in particular because clearly
Josh Reynolds was not able to rise to
the occasion it started getting his in
his head and I know maybe jarro G was
just playing out the play you know and
reading it out the way it's naturally
supposed to be read out but I'm telling
you if you're going to go ahead and be
aggressive then I'm definitely going to
make sure it's about players over plays
and I'm getting it to my best people and
I don't know if they necessarily did
that
um and they're going to have to live
with the
results yeah you just wonder it's set up
as well as it possibly could for the
lions that you had the Cowboys bow out
you know Tampa makes the playoffs you
don't worry about the Eagles uh it just
felt like okay you can beat San
Francisco Green Bay should have beaten
San Francisco and you're up 24
to7 how do you think how long does this
one sting oh it'll it'll sting it'll
sting forever simply because there's no
guarantee that they'll ever get back
there and he admitted that but is this
28-3 Falcons Patriots type of I mean I
mean obviously that's I mean obviously
that's Super Bowl but yeah but I mean
yeah it's still it still has that kind
of lingering like heartbreaking effect
look I remember my very first year um
working for Philadelphia in 2008 we made
it to the NFC championship game against
Kurt Warner and Arizona Cardinals down
there in
Arizona and I remember thinking man we
you know we got all the way here and
when we lost that game I remember that
flight home like I mean I didn't play
the game I was a scout there and I was
up in the booth helping that day but it
felt just crushing and we never got
close to getting back to that Andy never
got close getting back to that until he
got to Kansas City so it could be years
it could be years before they get back
there again and it's um and you know
what and I'll tell you what and I know
people you know I've heard this morning
people keep
saying Detroit gave that
game to San Francisco San Francisco
didn't win it Detroit lost it well you
know what okay I saw Brock Pie make some
very special plays I saw all of a sudden
Nick Bosa making some very special plays
I saw Fred Warner making some very
special plays that it wasn't just
Detroit giving it to him they took it
and yeah I think that's what makes this
game and as beautiful as it is and what
makes it as heartbreaking as it is is
because when you're that close and you
know that every single situation every
single
decision will go down in history as far
as whether or not you made it to a game
like the Super Bowl or you were just a
couple plays
away man that that's that's hard that's
hard to stomach and I and I don't
necessarily think teams necessarily lose
games like that I think it's more about
you know players making plays in crucial
situations that really are able to rise
to those to those moments and you saw
some guys rise to those moments
yesterday and some guys not be able to
rise to those moments I really think
that that that's I think we're kind of
cheating San Francisco to say they
should have lost to Green Bay or they
should lost yesterday yeah no in the
biggest of moments which is how we judge
the great players who play this sport
guys like Brock pie made plays Brandon
auk made plays Nick Bosa made plays Fred
Warner made the plays tan Gibson he he
stripped Jamir Gibbs because he's been
coached to do that and in the most
crucial of moments he made the play and
Jamir didn't secure the football that's
what separates in those moments man and
that's what's uh it was high drama
yesterday and yeah all of that
together it's got to be crushing for
Detroit
crushing good to talk to you Lewis uh
hopefully we'll see you in Las Vegas
thanks for joining us that man I'll see
you there that's Lewis rck aspn NFL
college football analyst